we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p call anytime
if you have questions comments
criticisms about the show here's a
government shutdown related idea that a
caller left on our voicemail line hey
David for every day the government is
shut down everyone that has the power to
open or shut down the government should
be fine for each day then they don't
know how we feel because I really need
to get paid I understand that and I
understand the frustration I understand
the desperation that a lot of people are
in right now when you consider that
something like 78 percent of the u.s.
population is effectively living
paycheck to paycheck that's something
like half the population would not be
able to afford an unexpected four
hundred dollar expense I understand
what's going on and I have friends who
are also not getting paid right now but
I don't think the idea of finding
everybody who has the power to open the
government is going to work I don't
think it'll work logistically and I
don't think it'll work theoretically if
you're Trump you don't care about some
kind of fine for every day that
government is closed if you're an
elected official I don't see how you can
be fined personally for the fact that
the government is not open so I
understand the frustration I sympathize
with what's going on and I empathize
with it as well but we need to make
decisions at the voting booth to prevent
these shutdowns from happening in the
first place rather than trying to put in
place a fine for people that are not
ending the shutdown because I just don't
think it'll work I don't think it's the
right focus but I but I hear you and I
understand why you're so frustrated and
I hope you know my friends who I spoke
to over the weekend they mostly said
this has basically gone on as long as
any shutdown so I'm sure that it'll be
open to any day now of course it's been
four more days since I spoke to them and
the government is still closed we have a
fantastic bonus show planned for you
today the father of DNA says he still
believes in a link between race and IQ
and his lab has now stripped him of his
titles we'll talk about a second us
judge
locking the Trump administration's birth
control rules that's very good news
we'll see if it holds up and stormy
Daniels the mistress of Donald Trump is
now suing the Columbus Ohio police over
that strip club arrest which
realistically I think we can say may
have been politically motivated we'll
talk about all three of those stories
and more on today's bonus show thanks to
everybody for watching make sure you
become a member at WWJ pakman.com or
make a patreon pledge at patreon.com
slash david pakman show because there is
more show available it's the bonus show
and it starts in just a couple of
minutes